No,
no, no, no, no, tell me, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, my
name is ribbon.  A maiden cat in love
Raise your femininity with a ribbon to appeal to cats who
care  When I was 100 years old, Mr. Niyama's sword fighting sprouted up.For
some reason, the number of cats decreased when I put them together with other
cats.Foot navigation
Finally reached the mansion new Soda meow
Hey, hide meow
[music]
meow  It's okay, but I've got 8 days to endure It's been a
long time The
lookout is over, meow
I can't
do it I wonder if there's something
wrong with Oike [music]
fun
mach
[music]
guu
me
goon